circle tangents y over X cotangent is
the x-coordinate over the y-coordinate
so if we want to graph tangent what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at negative PI over 2 if you go this
direction it's a negative angle to
positive PI over 2 you're going to
counterclockwise it's a positive angle
we're gonna look at these points along
the unit circle and we're gonna get our
tangent graph so let's go ahead and do
that right now so y equals tangent of X
okay if we start over here at negative
PI over 2 I'm going to the left because
it's negative and I'm going this
direction that's a negative angle this
direction is a positive angle so at
negative PI over 2 tangent is y over X
negative 1 divided by 0 is undefined
can't divide by 0 so we get a vertical
asymptote on our graph if we go to
negative PI over 4 right here tangent is
y over X negative square root 2 over 2
divided by positive square root 2 over 2
that's going to give you negative 1 if
you go to 0 tangent is 0 over 1 which is
0 positive PI over 4 Y over X is
positive 1 and if we go to PI over 2 0
over 1 is 0 sorry is everyone is well I
got I have my coordinates messed up here
this is at 0 comma 1 1 over 0 is
undefined so you can't divide by 0 so
there's your asymptote right there okay
so now when you look at your graph
tangent looks like like that so it gets
closer and closer to the asymptotes and
this will actually repeat like that
and like that and so on so you can see
from here to here one cycle one period
is pi so remember for sine and cosine
the period is 2 pi normally for tangent
and cotangent it completes one cycle and
1 pi okay so now what we're going to do
is we're going to look at what happens
if you stretch this graph compress this
graph and so on but before we do that
let's take a look at cotangent so we've
got the unit circle right here so
cotangent I'll put it right underneath
the tangent so you can kind of compare
and contrast cotangent we're going to
look at the points from 0 to 180 0 to PI
so cotangent X over Y so 1 over zero
that's undefined you can't divide by 0
so we get a vertical asymptote at PI
over 4 x over Y is 1 because anything
divided by itself is going to give you 1
at PI over 2 x over y 0 over 1 is 0 at 3
PI over 4 X divided by Y negative square
root 2 or 2 over positive square root 2
over 2 is negative 1 and then if we go
over 2 pi X over Y negative 1 over 0 is
undefined we get another vertical
asymptote so for cotangent
the graph looks like that and again it
repeats just like tangent okay
every pi so that's the period is pi now
what some students remember is that
tangents going up to the right co'tin is
going down to the right
tangent and 1/2 the graphs to the left
of the y-axis ok 1/2 to the right
whereas for cotangent the whole graph is
to the to the right of the y-axis here
ok so kind of notice a difference so
tangent have some left happens is on the
right side of the y-axis cotangent the
whole graph is to the right of the
y-axis they both have a period of Pi
okay and you can divide it up into 4
pieces like we did here these are the
basic parent graphs okay so what we're
going to do next is we're going to look
at the stretching and compressing in the
shifting just like we did with sine and
cosine so let's just take a look say I
want to graph y equals 2 tangent of X
what do you think the 2 does to the
graph that's right it stretches it so
instead of being here at 1 you're gonna
be up here at 2 now instead of being
here at negative one you're gonna be
down here at negative 2 this is a
vertical stretch so it's like you're
pulling on okay stretching it this way
ok that's the same thing for these ok
now if we look at cotangent let's say
for cotangent we want to graph y equals
cotangent of 2x okay what do you think
the two does to the graph well we can
use this formula period equals 1 pi
divided by V this is the B value - okay
so what that means it's completing one
cycle and PI over 2 so what it's going
to do is it's going to compress the
session going to divide the x-values by
2 it's going to complete one cycle
like this now it's compressing it okay
and then you can shift it to the left
and right up and down so I'm gonna erase
this real quick and we're gonna take a
look at some more difficult problems but
if you forget just go back to the unit
circle tangents Y over X from negative
90 to positive 90 cotangent from zero to
PI or zero to 180 that's x over Y for
cotangent and that's how you can get the
parent graphs and then you can stretch
them compress them shift them and so on
let's look at some more difficult
problems and you'll see what I mean
okay here's the good one right here
let's do y equals 1/2 tangent 1/2 X
minus PI plus 2 okay what I would do
just like we did for sine and cosines I
would graph the parent function using
the amplitude the a value and the B
value which affects the period then we
can pick up the graph and shift it right
pi remember this one has the opposite
effect this one has the same effect on
the graph plus 2 is actually up too so
let's start by graphing this one here
now I'm just going to start by graphing
the asymptotes I'm going to take the
period which is normally PI for tangent
and cotangent I'm going to divide it by
1/2 which gives you a period of 2 pi
because remember when you divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so that's like multiplying by
2 that's 2 pi but what I'm going to do
and this is what some students get a
little confused by half's on the right
side of the y-axis halves on the Left
I'm going to take this 2 pi I'm gonna
divide it in half so this is actually pi
here and negative pi giving you a period
of 2 pi I'm gonna divide it in half
again these are like our midway points
PI over 2 and negative PI over 2 and
then the amplitude is 1/2 so we're going
to go up here to 1/2 and
let's let me erase this a little bit let
me just put a half over here and
negative a half down here okay
and so our graphs gonna look like this
okay that's our parent graph okay but
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
shift it right pi and up to now on our
scale pi is actually two steps so
everything is going to shift two steps
to the right and up two steps okay so
what we have to do here is we're going
to take each of these asymptotes we're
gonna shift them right to so now your
asymptotes going to be right there this
one's going to go right here this point
is going to be go here and up two so I'm
just going to estimate for this this is
going to go right to okay and up to I'm
just gonna estimate for that and then
this one's going to go right to and up
two and so our graph now looks like that
okay the red graph so it shifted right
to and up to based on the scale that we
had okay so that's tangent let's do a
more challenging cotangent graph the key
I believe is to do it in steps
you know graph the amplitude and period
in one step then you can graph the the
shifted graph in the second step so
let's graph this cotangent graph let's
just say we're gonna graph y equals
negative cotangent let's just say this
is 2x minus PI over four
okay we'll just do this one a little bit
more simple so cotangent looks like this
there's the y-axis here's the x-axis it
goes down to the right like that
it's to the right of the y-axis where as
tangents halves on the Left halves on
the right the period is going to be two
pi divided by two I'm sorry one pi
tangent cotangent of periods normally PI
sine and cosine appeared it's two pi so
we take pi divided by two okay so that
means one period is going to be
completed in PI over two I'm going to
divide this into one two three four
pieces so this is PI over four PI over
eight and three PI over eight okay so
you could take PI over two divided by
four that's PI over eight and that's
going to give us our scale now the
negative what do you think the negative
does the negative reflects it over the x
axis it makes the positive Y value is
negative and the negative ones positive
and what do you think the PI over four
does shifts it right PI over four so
everything's going to shift even these
asymptotes okay right PI over four now
on our scale that's going to be two
units to the right because we're
counting by PI over eight okay so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
first I'm going to reflect this so the
graph looks like this okay and then it's
going to shift right PI over four so
these points are going to go one two one
two one two and the asymptotes also are
going to go one two and one two so your
graph now is going to look like like
this
okay it's going up to the right because
it was reflected over the x-axis by this
negative here so that's cotangent we
talked about tangent and if you just go
back to the parent function like I said
do the a and the B first and then you
can shift it second you'll have the
graph down so that's tangent and
cotangent take a look at the graphs I
did on sine and cosine for additional
pointers and we'll take a look at secant
and cosecant in the next video